on a gagné g son petit frères on voulait
pas le faire mal c'est pour ça on les a
gagné
30 mais bon
Alam mais bon
prierut
pas on l'appelle Stary franchement c'est
c'est un bon petit c'est un bon petit
qui est très qui travaille donc on est
très content prier match prière CAN et
doubl pour lui on est très très content
pour lui voilà c'est ça qu'on leur
demande de faire les jeunes qui sont là
ils sont pas là juste pour pour pour
compléter le groupe mais ils sont là
parce qu'ils méritent d'être là ils ont
des qualités et c'est ce qu'on attend
d'eux c'est un jeune joueur et les
jeunes joueurs il faut les laisser quand
même le temps de grandir mais faut dire
qu'au-delà même de ces deux buts là
c'est son c'est son volume de jeu sur le
terrain il a joué vraiment comme garçon
expérimenté nous allons continuer à le
protéger parce qu'il faut pas le il faut
pas le griller très tôt le football
c'est un jeu collectif si tous ces
garçon là émerge c'est parce que il y a
un collectif qui est là il y a un projet
commun et comme je l'ai dit je l'ai
toujours dit aux garçons collectivement
si on est bon les individualités se
verront
[Musique]